二個4個どうも
ティ1 ok って鈴れていますそれで2位に
はい1年間はい
ラーメンを我慢してはい
365日が1回も飛びませんでしたすごいですね本当に
結界だったら一発ではめちゃくちゃ練られて食いたいなと思ってちょっと雪ファンの
とこにお邪魔しておりましたうんうんと声だけでタイヤ用 os 本当にいいという
進めてみのおすすめのラーメンですか
そうですめちゃくちゃオススメなラーメンを教紹介しました1年ぶりのラーメンなんで
ハイ
ラベクっていうか
思いますはい
月号
ha
あ服にクールサインが最後言われますはい
big 石ね摂氏濡らしヒューマンって常にラーメン食べて
ラメとまぁな方は[ __ ]するしてるじゃないけどとするよ
まあブータンの従ったルーターフッターん maroon
お願いしますはいカチカチです何2ワーストラーメン食べに山牛丼ですねあー
てくることはなんか牛丼に逃げちゃって2年前に食べ過ぎたという
な面を早いもし毎日節句まで飲んで当然ですよねちゃんシュートっ
えっ
やファーって巡礼歌としてたらなんか人間ドッグで中選手も本当に身体の中に結構1回
が朝表示なんですいやバイって言われて
love 力士に行ったっていうそれゆえなんだそれでちょっとキレイなりましょう
からだな
なってレイラさあこれぞません
入った
オウムないんですよこんなもんすか我くださいはい
すげー
[音楽]
宇久井ですよ経済といった見て行くよじゃあ
1年ぶりのラーメンをいただきます見上げます
やばいマジで本当に常に良いですよ天一で12
結構創造池江たって前につ食べてるってこれは毎日ですさにあってですか
いいか ppd ですそ
[音楽]
本当に食べるか母いいのかな
がイースあっ
うわぁ
空のかいや止める事も言っちゃダメダメてましょうかピアノ俺はこれを食べてために1
年間我慢してきたところあるんで
はい
では
いただきますください
台です見ます
[音楽]
はいあーん今野由愛
これが1年から目食べてこなかった人のやつマジでも市でパッパッ広がったセントに
歩ん
何食べさせたりなって質疑で考えたんですけど
[音楽]
やっぱこういうガッツケルは音がいいかなと思うと
泣いてるんだよねなんじゃないけどする国紹介してもらったラーメンは
今まで食べてきたすべての旅本の中で
一番おいしい
心か
そう感じたんだ
快樂食べましたはいブザーばでしたらじゃあ
薬変えた至極の逸品でございます後はいえ良かった本当にでも質問影美味しかった大隣
も渡そうとに
いう僕が作ったんじゃないですよね大事件つけるわけないですねじゃあありがとうだよ
もうさぁさぁ
いやーやっぱりね我慢して初めて見える
光景もあるにアニメなんかまた今年も何かが我慢しようと思ってるんですけどちょっと
また近いうちに発表しようと思いますはい
最高の逸品でございましたございましたーーーを続け車バジャー
というわけで今年のスツール君がラーメン1年記事します new しない子だ
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
あっはぁ